shark alley lies at the southernmost
point of Africa abundant with the marine
and bird life it's home to thousands of
Cape fur seals these marine mammals are
a favourite with great white sharks the
Predators trollese waters in large
numbers on the lookout for their next
meal shark alley is also famous as one
of the world's top commercial cage
diving destinations the tourism brings
in revenue and also helps support
scientific research of the Sharks cage
diving industry here in funds by has
been operating for a number of years
many of these boats are collecting daily
observational data now to better protect
an animal we first have to know
something about it so we can't hope to
push legislations at higher levels if we
don't have that knowledge to first
investigate sharks of all species are in
need of protection almost 100 million
are killed each year
too many for the populations to recover
and some sharks are targeted simply
because they're perceived as dangerous
but that's an unjustified prejudice
sharks rarely view humans as prey there
are only around 5 shark attacks a year
in South Africa cage diving operators
used bait to attract the Sharks to the
cages it's a once-in-a-lifetime thrill
for the tourists their size theirs
the mystique that surrounds them you
know I don't live near an ocean and so
the only experience that I have with
sharks is what I see on TV and I in
movies and seeing them firsthand is I
don't think you can compare to anything
else yeah it's pretty amazing
recent studies indicate there may be
only a few thousand of the iconic great
white sharks left in the world back on
land Kelly Bakker analyzes the latest
data with her colleague like a
fingerprint each shark has a uniquely
shaped back fin the scientists are
interested in the animals migratory
behavior sharks with over 500 species
and they are ultimately incredible they
just continue to fascinate and
particularly for me the great white
shark it's kind of the ultimate iconic
charismatic or inspiring species but yet
we still have no idea where it breeds
and where it mates despite the amount of
telemetric focus it has on it
understanding where and when the Sharks
reproduce is vital for their
conservation great whites are especially
slow to produce offspring as females
need around 30 years to reach sexual
maturity and can only made ten or
fifteen times in their lifetime which is
very infrequent for fish species
long-term conservation success will
require a change in the perception of
the animals in nearby Cape Town the save
our seas foundation invests in shark
education the aim is to introduce
schoolchildren to the marine environment
from an early age
it's they only know that sharks are
dangerous sharks are eating people so
here we're trying to change their minds
trying to teach them to know that sharks
are not dangerous as they think sharks
are useful to ask people because they
keep our oceans in balance they clean
our oceans the message of save our seas
is clear sharks like humans rely on
healthy oceans to survive so we need to
learn to live with the sea and its
inhabitants not against them in shark
alley marine biologist Kelly Baker is
back on the tourist boat here sharks are
already celebrated stars we have looked
at for for so many years we still know
so little about it so what I would like
to do or what I hope that we can do is
to to further our knowledge on this
animal in turn then need to perhaps a
better idea of exactly how vulnerable
this species is and what we can do to
better protect it there's plenty of
research still to be done besides the
charismatic great white one hundred
other shark species can be found in the
waters of South Africa